hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about the four things to avoid if you
have an enlarged prostate
okay now I've observed this with a lot
of clients over the last 29 years okay
and the first one I want to talk about
is this one right here dairy okay that
includes cheese milk yogurt cream cheese
sour cream even butter why because I
noticed when men then have enlarged
prostates consume dairy what happens is
they have a difficult time going to the
bathroom because their prostate swells
up even more the prostate is kind of
like a sponge for hormones so where does
dairy come from it comes from milk a
pregnant cow used to grow a calf okay so
it's growth hormones growth factors so
we want to avoid dairy if you have a
prostate problem okay if you don't have
a prostate problem I think a high
quality dairy like an in the form of
grass-fed occasionally is going to be
totally fine okay number two vegetable
oils the problem is in the salad
dressings you have all these vegetable oils
that are omega-6 okay those are
inflammatory soy corn canola not to
mention their GMO which is a whole other
topic so that's going to be inflammatory
for the prostate you can totally do
olive oil okay in vinaigrette that's not
a problem that's the type of dressing
you need on your salad all right number
three sugar that's a given I'm sure you
already know that you have to avoid
sugar because that's going to be
inflammatory and of course the things
that turn into sugar like grains breads
and pasta and things like that
number four soy soy protein isolates
there's a lot of products out there with
soy we mentioned the oil right here but
just soy in general can enlarge the
prostate because it can actually give
you estrogenic factors okay so there you
have it the four things that you want to
avoid if you have an enlarged prostate
hey guys so there's a whole bunch of
people that really need this information
so press the share button and let's get
it way out there